sie strahlten mit ihren goldmedaillen um
die wette aljona savchenko und bruno
mars so wurden dem deutschen aus im
klang ausgiebig gefeiert
die beiden hatten im eiskunstlauf das
erste olympische paarlauf gold für
deutschland seit 66 jahren geholt und
mit einer grandiosen kür von der einige
sagen es sei die beste aller zeiten
gewesen publikum und preisrichter
verzaubert in ihrem an die natur film
die erde von oben gesehen angelegten
vortrag gelang dem paar einfach alles
damit machten sie den rückstand aus dem
kurzprogramm noch gut und konnten sich
die goldmedaille sichern
es sei wohl die beste kür ihres lebens
gewesen sagte schenker ja wir waren also
wir waren wie in einen tunnel sage ich
mal so weil alles hat funktioniert und
man hat als zu dieser konstellation von
anfang bis zu ende wo wir vierte element
gemacht haben haben habe ich gedacht wir
also jetzt darfst du nicht dicht hängen
lassen weil ich heute schon noch mehr
gas geben
aber manchmal ist so wenn man zu viel
gibt dann passiert und welche fehler und
ich dachte halte ich einfach zurück
heiligen wachsen
grund zum jubeln hatten auch wieder
einmal die deutschen rennrodler nach
gold für natalie geisenberger im
einzelnen von tobias wendt und tobias
arlt im doppelsitzer rodelte auch die
deutsche team staffel zum sieg
und das mit einem riesigen vorsprung vor
der konkurrenz